por qué
cuáles son exactamente las cartas que
han conducido a putin a elevar la
tensión en el este de europa hasta
niveles propios de la guerra fría cuáles
son las fortalezas de rusia en el actual
conflicto con ucrania
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas putin quieren
devolver a rusia su grandeza político y
militar en un pasado vídeo aquí en
visual político os contamos como la
invasión de ucrania podría convertirse
en toda una trampa para el futuro de
rusia os contamos incluso como los eeuu
podrían estar deseando que las tropas
rusas atravesarán la frontera ucraniana
ahora bien es evidente que moscú tiene o
al menos tuvo cálculos muy diferentes
durante las dos últimas décadas el país
ha cambiado mucho y el gobierno de putin
se siente hoy más fuerte que nunca
amigos amigas puede que no sean
suficientes pero en este vídeo vamos a
ver las cuatro fortalezas las cuatro
cartas que han llevado a vladimir putin
a desatar la última gran crisis
político-militar en el continente
europeo atentos
el poder de la fuerza
cuando el día 31 de diciembre de 1999
putin se hizo con los mandos de la
federación rusa las fuerzas armadas de
este país no atravesaban precisamente su
mejor momento por aquel entonces el
ejército ruso era poco más que una vieja
estructura oxidada cuyas capacidades se
reducían día tras día por ejemplo la
otra ahora poderosa flota de submarinos
nucleares soviéticos luchaba por
sobrevivir la fuerza aérea se enfrentaba
a todo tipo de calamidades las tropas
carecían del equipamiento más básico y
tanto ellos como los propios oficiales
vivían en viviendas destartaladas y
ruidosas para colmo la guerra de
chechenia se había convertido en algo
así como una pesadilla interminable
digamos que por aquel entonces la moral
como los a varios militares estaban por
los suelos
[Música]
pues bien vladimir putin intentó mejorar
las cosas pero con todo no fue hasta el
año 2008 cuando se produjo un punto de
inflexión ese año el ejército ruso atacó
georgia un pequeño país del cáucaso y
sabéis que a pesar de la enorme
superioridad de fuerzas las carencias
del ejército ruso se pusieron enseguida
sobre la mesa se produjeron todo tipo de
problemas por ejemplo las tropas
terrestres no tenían comunicación
directa con la fuerza aérea lo que
provocó varios ataques graves con fuego
amigo los tanques y los vehículos de
transporte sufrieron un montón de
averías la coordinación entre los
diferentes mandos militares fue más bien
inexistente no había armamento de
precisión y la preparación de las tropas
era simple y llanamente desastrosas
[Música]
la guerra de georgia amigos fue el
auténtico punto de inflexión para rusia
desde ese momento vladimir putin situó
una reforma militar como toda una
prioridad nacional bajo su punto de
vista rusia tenía que reconstruir y
modernizar su ejército por completo pues
bien tal y como solemos decir por aquí
dicho y hecho
desde 2008 la situación del ejército
ruso ha cambiado por completo vladimir
putin ha impulsado un enorme proceso de
inversión y renovación de las fuerzas
armadas hoy el ejército ruso es más
pequeño pero mucho más operativo y
moderno las unidades tienen mejor
equipamiento las capacidades de
despliegue se han multiplicado la fuerza
aérea ha incorporado cientos de nuevas
aeronaves y la marina está desplegando
sus submarinos nucleares clase borei
desde entonces la transformación ha sido
muy importante en prácticamente todos
los campos pero queréis algún ejemplo
concreto pues ahí tenemos sin ir más
lejos el caso de los tanques t-72 que se
han desplegado en la frontera con
ucrania estos tanques cuentan ahora con
un nuevo sistema de óptica térmica que
les permite combatir por la noche luego
los misiles de crucero caliber
desplegados en barcos y submarinos en el
mar negro así como los cohetes iskander
m desplegados a lo largo de la frontera
pueden alcanzar objetivos en casi
cualquier lugar del interior de ucrania
y son sólo dos ejemplos
[Música]
las fuerzas armadas rusas han cambiado
radicalmente desde que vladimir putin
llegó al poder algo que le ha permitido
al kremlin multiplicar sus incursiones
en el exterior con bastante éxito ahí
están sin ir más lejos las operaciones
de crimea o siria así como los
despliegues rápidos en armenia o
kazajistán de hecho rusia ha utilizado
estas intervenciones para afinar sus
estrategias y ganar experiencia
operativa y de combate algo que resulta
clave a la hora de llevar a cabo
operaciones militares de esta forma
según ha comunicado el ministro de
defensa ruso serguéi sal con todos los
comandantes de tropas terrestres el 92
por ciento de los pilotos de la fuerza
aérea y el 62% de las unidades de la
armada tienen experiencia en el campo de
batalla
por supuesto las fuerzas armadas rusas
aún tienen muchas limitaciones como por
ejemplo el acceso a la tecnología punta
o poder tener el respaldo de una
economía fuerte para financiar su
desarrollo pero pese a ello es evidente
que la situación es totalmente diferente
a la del año 2000
[Aplausos]
así que la primera gran fortaleza con la
que cuenta a putin en lo que respecta a
la crisis de ucrania es precisamente
poder esperar que llegado el caso el
ejército ruso está en situación de
realizar una intervención limpia y
rápida algo que supondría no sólo un
importante golpe en la mesa sino que
además les permitiría pasar muy rápido a
una nueva fase en todo este conflicto
político militar es evidente que contar
con unas fuerzas armadas preparadas
incrementa mucho el número de opciones
así como también el poder de negociación
claro que esta puede ser la fortaleza
más obvia pero no es ni mucho menos la
única y probablemente tampoco la baza
más importante con la que putin cuenta
para intentar salirse con la suya
atentos
[Música]
el plan fortaleza rusia
las sanciones económicas y financieras
con las que eeuu y la unión europea
castigaron a rusia tras la ocupación de
crimea le asestó un duro golpe a la
economía de este país tal y como os
contamos en un pasado vídeo las
sanciones contribuyeron a hundir el
ingreso disponible el crecimiento
económico y la inversión extranjera en
rusia pues bien ahora accidente ha
vuelto a poner sobre la mesa la amenaza
de poner más y más sanciones unas
sanciones que el gobierno ruso espera
que llegado el caso puedan digerir para
lograrlo llevan preparándose desde el
año 2014 con una estrategia que ha
venido a ser comúnmente conocida como el
plan fortaleza rusia
[Música]
en 2014 el gobierno ruso comprendió que
las sanciones internacionales podrían
causar un enorme daño no sólo a la
economía rusa sino también a las propias
capacidades del gobierno para tomar
decisiones sin recursos es difícil tener
una política exterior efectiva
precisamente por eso el gobierno ruso
comprendió que tenía que preparar su
economía para poder soportar en la
medida de lo posible nuevas sanciones de
esta forma equilibrar las cuentas
públicas aumentar sus reservas de
divisas y reducir la dependencia del
dólar se convirtieron en objetivos
fundamentales de la política económica
y querida comunidad de visual política
eso es exactamente lo que han hecho para
el kremlin la prioridad absoluta ha sido
preparar al gobierno para ha llegado el
caso poder soportar el impacto de
fuertes sanciones sin que yo limite al
menos en el corto plazo sus capacidades
para actuar de esta forma durante todos
estos años el gobierno ruso ha
equilibrado sus cuentas públicas y ha
construido una enorme reserva de divisas
equivalente a más de seiscientos mil
millones de dólares al tiempo que se ha
reducido la deuda externa fijaos
ah
la idea es que si se reconoce un
conflicto con eeuu y la unión europea y
el gobierno ruso pueda utilizar esta
enorme cantidad de dinero como un balón
de oxígeno o un apunte importante parece
mucho muchísimo dinero pero tenemos que
tener en cuenta que también hablamos de
un país de más de 140 millones de
habitantes en cualquier caso moscú
también cuenta con que los cada vez
mayores precios del petróleo y del gas
le permitan incrementar aún más estas
reservas de divisas durante los próximos
años o sea está mucho mejor preparada
para las canciones que en 2014 al menos
en lo que respecta a sus macro
indicadores el sector estatal está en
buena forma y el colchón financiero es
grande natalia la globa economista jefe
del vice spencer group en moscú además
rusia también ha estado reduciendo su
exposición al dólar e incrementando el
peso que otras divisas como por ejemplo
el euro o el yuan chino tienen tanto en
sus reservas de divisas como sobre todo
en las propias relaciones comerciales
del país fijaos
[Música]
y si tal y como os contamos en un pasado
vídeo aquí en visual político a medio y
largo plazo las sanciones
internacionales pueden causar un enorme
daño a la economía rusa sobre esta
cuestión existen muy pocas dudas el
impacto a medio y largo plazo de llevar
a rusia a la autarquía financiera y
económica así como el coste para los
ciudadanos sería enorme el crecimiento
potencial será mucho menos sin
interacción con el mundo el inah
rivacoba economista jefe adjunta del
instituto internacional de finanzas
ahora bien no hablamos precisamente del
país más democrático libre y
transparente del mundo para el kremlin
la cuestión principal no es si las
sanciones condenaran o no a la economía
rusa o el nivel de vida de la población
digamos que son en cierto modo es lo de
menos lo importante si el gobierno puede
soportar las sin ver limitada sus
operaciones y su capacidad de influencia
al menos durante unos cuantos años pues
bien gracias a esta política al plan
fortaleza rusia el kremlin es para poder
contar con un margen de actuación
suficiente sea cual sea finalmente su
decisión al tiempo que también esperan
poder convencer a los gobiernos europeos
para que adopten una posición más tibia
sobre todo si la intervención en ucrania
fuera limitada porque vladimir putin
amigos tiene más en la manga por ejemplo
lo que podemos denominar como las
contras sanciones atentos
[Música]
mensaje de moscú europa no te pegues un
tiro en el pie
no creo que sorprenda a nadie si digo
que rusia es un importantísimo
exportador de productos básicos como el
gas el petróleo los fertilizantes el
aluminio el acero el platino el oro o el
níquel entre muchos otros
hablamos de suministros que en muchos
casos son esenciales para las empresas y
las economías europeas eso es lo que
ocurre por ejemplo con el gas la unión
europea' amigos importa más del 40 por
ciento de todo el gas que consume desde
rusia de esta forma si las sanciones
fueran excesivamente agresivas podrían
afectar al propio acceso de las
economías europeas a todos estos inputs
como por ejemplo al gas de los cuales
algunos países como austria finlandia
alemania o polonia son enormemente
dependientes
[Música]
e
y ojo porque sustituir el gas ruso no
supone una tarea nada pero que nada
sencilla primero porque el gas natural
liquado que sería la única alternativa
real es mucho más caro y segundo porque
hoy por hoy los países productores no
tienen mucho margen para vender europa
tendría que quitarle el gas a las
economías asiáticas a golpe de talonario
evidentemente toda esta situación es un
importante factor disuasorio las
sanciones podrían dificultar las
relaciones comerciales al tiempo que
rusia podría incluso reducir o suspender
el suministro de muchas materias primas
como elemento de presión de esta forma
vemos que están convencidos de que al
final los grandes gobiernos de la unión
europea harían todo lo posible para que
las cosas no se fueran de madre y se
aplicarán sanciones mucho más limitadas
de lo que les gustaría en washington
sobre todo además si hablamos de una
invasión limitada o parcial y ojo porque
podemos encontrar un importante
precedente atentos
[Música]
en 2018 estados unidos impuso sanciones
contra rusal la principal compañía rusa
de aluminio por sus lazos con el
oligarca cercano al kremlin oleg
deripaska las sanciones provocaron que
los precios se dispararan un 30% lo que
afectó a todo tipo de industrias desde
los fabricantes de vehículos a los de
las latas de refresco la presión fue tan
grande que apenas unos meses después
washington decidió levantar las
sanciones
de momento gazpron el gigante ruso la
energía ha estado durante el 2021
reduciendo el suministro de gas a europa
algo que ha reducido las reservas del
continente y presionado al alzar los
precios esto ha contribuido a que según
las estimaciones de citi morgan la
factura energética de europa se haya
duplicado el del 2019 y ojo que no
hablamos de unos pocos euros sino de
aproximadamente 500.000 millones de
dólares de sobrecoste si lo habéis
escuchado bien quinientos mil millones
de dólares anuales
e
digamos que moscú está utilizando algo
así como una teoría de juegos por un
lado saben que a medio y largo plazo
necesitan que europa les siga comprando
sus materias primas y saben que reducir
o suspender el suministro podría
conllevarle tal y como ya os contamos en
un pasado vídeo grandes pérdidas a largo
plazo pero en cambio a corto plazo las
cosas podrían ser muy diferentes la
enorme dependencia que las economías
europeas tienen de muchos suministros
rusos es un factor de presión que moscú
espera no o al menos esperaban utilizar
para obtener un gran triunfo diplomático
y ojo porque aún no hemos terminado
putin aún tiene una cuarta carta bajo su
manga atentos
el dragón chino al rescate
[Música]
a ver que históricamente los rusos y los
chinos han llevado peor que mal fatal
sin embargo en los últimos años la
situación ha cambiado bastante por
ejemplo pocos líderes acumulan tantas
citas como vladimir putin y xi jinping
para que os hagáis una idea del amor que
se profesan estos dos líderes políticos
han visto las caras y frotando las manos
casi 40 veces y lo que resulta aún mucho
más importante
según los datos de china el volumen de
comercio entre ambos países superó en
2021 los 145 mil millones de dólares el
gigante asiático es ya el primer socio
comercial de rusia y para 2024 se espera
que el comercio bilateral haya superado
los 200 mil millones
[Música]
de esta forma si las cosas se ponen feas
en el oeste moscú cree que la economía
china que tiene enormes cantidades de
divisas y devora materias primas como si
no hubiera mañana podría ser todo un
flotador para rusia al menos para evitar
el peor de los escenarios
creo que putin probablemente recibió
algunas garantías de sí de que si
estalla una crisis sobre ucrania y
occidente impone sanciones importantes
contra rusia entonces china estará
hombro con hombro con rusia artyom
looking profesor de relaciones
internacionales de la universidad
federal del extremo oriente claro que
esto tiene dos problemas por un lado
china no puede sustituir completamente a
las economías occidentales
económicamente una rusia con menos
occidente y más china sería mucho
muchísimo más débil por otra parte
provocaría una enorme dependencia de la
economía rusia hacia china algo que
podéis quererme moscú no hace ninguna
gracia porque pueden que en el kremlin
se fíe un poco de los norteamericanos
pero no penséis que en realidad piensan
muy diferente de los chinos ahora bien
puede que confíen en que la propia
amenaza de que se refuercen los lazos
entre china y rúsia actúe por sí mismo
como otro factor de disuasión sea como
sea estas son las cuatro grandes cartas
con la escribirá de unir putin ha
querido jugar esta partida
el problema para rusia es que tal y como
os contamos en un pasado vídeo esta vez
los eeuu parecen haber decidido verle la
apuesta y lo cierto es que las cartas de
putin aunque importantes no son tan
fuertes sobre todo porque en este juego
rusia tiene mucho que perder y muy poco
que ganar exactamente lo contrario a la
posición de eeuu si no hay duda hoy
rusia está mucho más preparada para
aguantar la ofensiva política de
occidente que hace 10 o 15 años pero a
largo plazo las cosas son distintas las
acciones la búsqueda alternativas
energéticas a rusia y la carrera militar
en la frontera europea le supondrían un
duro golpe al país y todo para que pues
básicamente para nada y quizás de hecho
esto es lo que expliqué porque rusia aún
no ha intervenido si realmente hubiera
querido hacerlo si realmente putin
hubiera querido invadir ucrania lo
normal es que ya lo hubiese hecho
las tropas rusas llevan listas muchos
meses y una acción rápida hubiera sido
una importante ventaja en la mesa de
negociación por así decirlo hubieran
pillado desprevenidos a los miembros de
la otan tanto a nivel militar como
político todo apunta a que lejos de
pensar en ucrania lo que putin quería
hacer sobre todo era reforzar el peso
internacional de rusia y enviar una
advertencia al resto de países de su
órbita incluido por supuesto aquí y
fracturar la otan y lo cierto es que
teniendo en cuenta cuál fue la reacción
inicial de países como francia y
alemania que fueron partidarios de
buscar la conciliación e incluso de
alejarse de washington puede que putin
no estuviera lejos de salirse con la
suya sin embargo en esta ocasión la
contundente reacción de los eeuu parecen
haber cambiado las tornas pero dicho
esto turno para ti que es que finalmente
putin invadir a ucrania de hacerlo qué
tipo de envergadura crees que tendría la
operación como tendrían que reaccionar
en ese caso los países de la otan que es
que rusia realmente ganaría algo déjanos
por aquí abajo tus comentarios y si este
año te resultó interesante no olvides de
la like y suscribirte a visual política
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]